Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new hulk video apparently marvel is working on
a new hulk movie according to all these reports
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel i do marvel videos every week
be sure to subscribe to get everything but
just explaining what's going on if you didn't see
the news the past couple of days there's been all
these reports posting several websites now talking
about marvel currently developing a new hulk movie
in the next couple of years so if you weren't
familiar with the backstory on this everybody's
been wondering when we're gonna see another hulk
solo movie the whole reason why marvel hasn't made
another one since the incredible hulk movie with
edward norton's hulk is because back in the 90s
when marvel went bankrupt they sold off the movie
rights to a lot of their biggest characters that's
how sony got the rights to all the spider-man
characters not just peter parker spider-man but
every character from the spider-man comics which
is like 900 characters total fox purchased the
rights to x-men fantastic four and then universal
got the rights to hulk namor and everything else
from the hulk comics so zoom in enhance on this
handy chart this is updated after marvel got the
rights to x-men and fantastic four after avengers
end game came out which is why only the spider-man
and the hulk namor characters are overlapping with
other studios and if you remember a couple years
ago when the marvel actors were doing press for
avengers infinity war and mark ruffalo had that
really funny moment where he kind of spoiled the
ending of infinity war saying everyone dies wait
till you see this next one everybody dies dude
not everybody he was half right they killed half
of all people and during those interviews he
was asked about doing another hulk solo movie
because it was around the time they were releasing
thor ragnarok with a bunch of hulk in that movie
and mark ruffalo basically went off spilling the
tea on universal claiming that he didn't think
that it would ever happen because apparently
universal hates making money for some reason
like don cheadle is here joking with him about
it i want to just make one thing perfectly clear
today a stand-alone hulk movie will never happen
tell me why because universal has the rights to
the standalone hulk movie and for some reason
they don't know how to play well with marvel
and and they don't want to make money and
with you as the new hulk it would be terrible
so that's really probably that's probably because
we know that these corporations would work it
out if they thought they'd make enough money so i
think about who's playing home but i mean i figure
i got like two or three more years left before
that i'm too old to play the hall and then let's
be honest you're kind of too old now let's just be
real but seriously this is something that you're
trying to make happen and it's just not gonna we
talked about it but i i just i don't see it in
the cards do you see it in the cards no i see i
can't believe you asked the question yeah i mean
there's a little cruel of it it was that's all
right that's okay you could see how easy it is it
i mean i feel like we're like
rosencrantz and guildenstern a little bit
thanks you know clearly he was very bitter about
it at the time but that was his way of saying
that kevin feige and the marvel people just had
not been able to make a deal with universal but
remember this was a couple years ago which is
why instead of doing hulk solo movies they just
gave hulk a larger story arc that crossed over
the avengers movies and thor ragnarok like they
gave him a planet hulk movie within a bunch of
other movies then more recently in the last couple
of years marvel still had the tv rights to the
hulk characters so they could do hulk tv shows
no problem and then disney plus came along which
is why she-hulk was one of the early series that
they green lit and they would just do more bruce
banner incredible hulk during that and obviously
abomination that we saw just come back in the
shang chi movie in other hulk characters from
the comics so after avengers end game came out
mark ruffalo did this big comic-con event where
he announced his involvement with the she-hulk
series during that he also said that he'd been
pitching kevin feige and marvel on hulk movies
and an incredible hulk revival tv show so even
though everyone's reporting this week that marvel
has reached a deal with universal somehow for a
new hulk movie failing that i just assumed
that marvel's plan b would always be to do
an incredible hulk disney plus series either
way i have no idea what black magic spell
marvel and disney lawyers perform to work
out this legal stuff out with universal
but the other big thing about all these news
reports is that they're saying this new hulk movie
would be partially based on the world war hulk
concept from the comics they wouldn't be able to
do the exact storyline because world war hulk was
what happened right after planet hulk hulk's wife
on sakhar gets killed by a member of his war bound
group and comrades because they want to keep hulk
angry and powerful they don't want him settling
down and living a quiet family life in outer space
and in his grief hulk becomes the maddest
that he's ever been in marvel comics history
in the whole thing with his game of powers is
the matter he gets the more powerful he gets
so he becomes the most powerful version of the
hulk and they call him world breaker hulk he
declares war on the illuminati the avengers the
x-men the entire earth basically and comes back
to break everyone smash them into piles of goo
which he does it was a great storyline but we've
already done the planet hulk arc in thor ragnarok
we've already done avengers infinity war avengers
end game professor hulk we just saw hulk during
the shang chi post credit scene and he's bruce
banner again so he's no longer professor hulk
like he's gone back to being banner so a lot
of comic book fans now are saying how do they
change the world war hulk story line so that
it makes sense given the plot of marvel phase 4
so far because he seems pretty chill right now
what could possibly happen to the hook now in
marvel phase 4 that would cause him to become
so mad that he turns into world breaker hulk
now obviously the shengshi post credit scene
with hulk is meant to kind of tee him up for the
she-hulk series like remind everyone hey we're
going to be seeing a version of him show up in
she-hulk looking like this the news reports that
her talking about this new hulk movie also claimed
that the she-hulk episodes will help set up this
new hulk solo movie somehow but here's the thing
kevin feige told us last year that the she-hulk
series is supposed to be kind of like a ally
mcbeal half-hour legal comedy kind of series
just with a whole bunch of whole characters
and other deep cuts coming back for cameos
there's even a report that says daredevil will
make a cameo because she hulk and daredevil are
both lawyers by day the only thing i think is sus
about some of these reports is that people are
claiming that the hulk movie would actually start
production late next year and i think it's just
too early for that because there's so many delays
and marvel just announced that all their marvel
phase 4 movies after spider-man no way home are
getting bumped by one slot so with all the delays
if this new hulk movie is legit then i don't think
that they'd actually start working on it for real
until like 2023 or later so even though this
all sounds really cool don't freak out too much
about this right now like don't hold your breath
but early theory they would use this new hulk
project to set up red hulk thunderbolt ross in
furtherance of all the val cameo scenes in falcon
and winter soldier black widow all the really big
anti-hero characters that they're bringing back
like abomination and for setting up full-blown
dark avengers i think the idea with all the val
cameo scenes is that some of the people that
she's recruiting are for thunderbolt stuff like
b-tier stuff and then some of the stuff she's
doing is also for setting up full-blown dark
avengers a-level stuff the funny thing about
red hulk too is that william hurt in real life
is this huge hulk comic book fan which was part
of the reason why he signed on to be thunderbolt
ross in the mcu for the first incredible hulk
movie originally they were going to do a whole
trilogy of movies so i think that they had planned
eventually to do some sort of big red hull twist
obviously things played out very differently but
if you saw him during the black widow movie there
was actually this deleted scene where he shows up
to arrest natasha and she basically convinces him
not to arrest her if you look at him in this
scene does it not look like something weird
is going on with him look this is all part
of the val stuff that they're doing building
up to this big reveal that they'll pay off in a
future movie and i think the idea is that we'll
see more of that get paid off by the time they
do the captain america 4 movie like how do you
get people pumped up to see captain america 4 well
you do it as kind of a dark avengers type of movie
early theory too since it sounds like we wouldn't
see this new world war hulk movie for a long time
by that time you know couple years down the road
kevin feige will have already figured out who
the new wolverine of the mcu is going to be and
they'll introduce him during the hulk movie either
they'll just tease him in a post-credit scene or
they'll do full blown hulk vs wolverine in the
movie and pay off the wolverine's first appearance
in the comics because he debuted in a hulk vs
wolverine story they didn't add all the weapon x
stuff to his backstory till later in the comics
in hulk and wolverine's first fight ended in a
stalemate before they could finish it they had
several rematches through the years like they
have an epic rivalry in the comics they didn't
really confirm a definitive winner until the old
man logan storyline which is kind of an elseworlds
non-canonical alternate post-apocalyptic future
story where most of earth's heroes are killed off
hulk has become an evil version of himself kind
of like the maestro but not the maestro completely
different character just another version of
the hulk and wolverine winds up killing him
after letting himself get eaten by the hook like
he literally just claws his way out of the hulk
stomach so everyone post all your theories in the
comments how do you think that they would change
the world war hulk storyline to fit the marvel
phase 4 story so far like what could possibly make
hulk so mad that he becomes world breaker hulk i
will be doing full episode videos for she-hulk i
think that those episodes are supposed to be
released sometime early next year but they've
kind of changed the schedule for the disney plus
shows a little bit they're doing a big comic con
event a big disney plus day where it'll be like
trail or city so we'll probably find out what's
happening with that stuff then that'll be later
this month make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss any of that stuff
it's gonna be crazy the next big marvel thing
that's coming up is the eternals movie so my post
credit scene video my full breakdown easter eggs
for that we'll post after the movie comes out
and then my full hawkeye episode videos will
start posting everyone click here for that brand
new adam warlock guardians of the galaxy 3 teaser
the james gunn just dropped and click here for my
shang chi post credit scene video with the hulk
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!